let's go to our next caller our next
caller is from the where are we going we
will go to the 8:45 area code caller
from 8:45 you are on go ahead
hey Mark Benjamin from Congress New York
yeah go ahead mark I I've been wondering
this ever since the summit between Putin
and Trump at this point I just kind of
assumed every politician is dirty to the
point of no return and must have
relatively new so besides the corruption
about the Trump Russia thing I want to
know is is is he just trying to make a
better elite like I don't know if he got
the idea or anything like that I'm
saying is he trying to dump our Western
allies for the eastern allies because
they're becoming a more economic power
or something like that I know that
attributes a lot of sort of like
critical thinking and rationality and
imagination isn't I'm saying that him as
a the one directing I'm saying like is
somebody pushing him towards that and
like to dump our Western because of I
don't know about the ins and outs of the
yes there's no reason to think right now
that whoever is pushing Trump to be
hostile to our historical allies and to
be totally friendly with Putin that it's
for some just general a general nice
idea of having better allies in the East
than in the West and and case in point
there are countries in Asia that Donald
Trump continues to worsen relationships
with so no I just I just don't I don't
think that's the goal and I'd also don't
think that's what's happening and do you
think it's a net good if we have any
sort of peace with Russia we're not at
war with Russia we're not at war with
Russia that the question is whether
Trump's being banned I'm not
antagonistic like in it's great to get
along with countries it's great to get
along with countries it's just when you
have specific evidence that a country
has done all of these different things
and then you have a leader who seems
unwilling to certainly to even recognize
and
and particularly to do a thing about it
and it seemed seeming to get even more
involved with these forces you have to
question their motives you know Marek
thank you I appreciate the call